epic games developed with them game
engines and games and we both the two
together synergistically so we're
constantly pushing the state of the art
and technology forward based on actually
shipping games and using it for products
epic Nvidia been working together for
years probably more than a decade now we
love those guys and we have people there
virtually every day on site and now that
partnership we've created a huge amount
of base technology which is advanced
schemes often a Samaritan demo the
elemental demo infiltrator demo all
arose from collaboration between Nvidia
and epic
we've been working with them in
particular lately on implementing the
latest engine Unreal Engine 4 on NVIDIA
Tegra k1 the cool thing about that is
that Unreal Engine 4 is their next
generation game engine which exploits
things like the dx11 feature set and now
that same technology is coming to mobile
so Tegra k1 is our latest SOC or
system-on-a-chip and the most exciting
thing about that is that it integrates
Kepler our latest GeForce GPU
architecture it's capable of dx11 class
features or opengl 4.4 things like
tessellation and compute shaders the
great thing about full opengl on mobile
hardware is that you can take absolutely
anything that runs on PC or high-end
console and run it on a Tegra hardware
from here onward I think we're going to
see the performance on feature yet
between mobile and PC and high-end game
and continue genera to the point where
the differences between the platforms
really blurred
one of the really exciting demos that
we've got going on in videos Tegra k1 is
the reflections demo using epics Unreal
Engine 4 it does things like real-time
reflections specular highlights shadows
it uses a bunch of advanced features
like cube map arrays and compute shaders
to do super sophisticated lighting and
it has a really sophisticated
post-processing pipeline for things like
blur and depth of field and bokeh to get
a really nice film like effect one of
the really important capabilities of the
game engine is the ability to display
very accurate recreations of real-life
scenes and we put together the realistic
rendering demo to show what a physically
accurate team looks like with the proper
reflections and proper lighting and
proper light fall-off aimed at
simulating reality exactly as opposed to
creating a fantastical sci-fi
environment one of the things that some
pretty high tech as its doing called
high dynamic range rendering you look
out the window and you get the bright
light it models the pupillary response
your iris would contract and then you
turn away from the window and you look
into darker parts of the room it takes a
little while for your eye to react to
less light coming into it and for your
pupil to open back up all of that is
modeled entirely in real time with
sophisticated computers so that's pretty
cool NVIDIA has done a really amazing
job with Tegra k1 hooked with the
hardware and with the software stacked
on top of it I didn't think that we
would be at this level one level for
another three or four years
you